part of the realization that Bernie Sanders
can be the nominee comes down to money raising
money.
Now I hate the system. We have the money in
politics system. We have raising money, political
ad spending, super packs, dark money. It's
toxic, it's corrosive, it's disgusting. It
has to be eliminated as soon as possible as
a top priority. That being said, I live in
reality and for the time being, it is the
system that we have. So raising money, uh,
raising more money from more people is a good
sign about your candidacies viability. Bernie
Sanders has crushed fundraising in the fourth
quarter of 2019 now, I want to be clear, once
again, I know there are people in the audience
who say, David, you're not pro Bernie enough.
Others say, David, you are too pro Bernie.
I'm reporting to you how the campaign is going,
period. And the way it went in the fourth
quarter of 2019 is that Bernie Sanders raised
34 and a half million dollars.
This is more than any other candidate who
has reported Q4 fundraising. So far we haven't
gotten Biden's numbers yet, or Warren's, although
Warren has alluded to her numbers, this is
the biggest single fundraising quarter for
any of the candidates and the democratic primary
from the entire year of 2019 the money from
1.8 million donations. Now this is a tricky
number because one person can donate many
times. There's a maximum number of dollars
that you can donate, but you can split it
up into a whole bunch of $10 donations or
whatever. So the 1.8 million donations number
is not a super relevant number to me, but
what we do know is that of the 34 and a half
million that Bernie raised, 18 million, nearly
half of it came just in December, which is
an accelerating donation curve. Some other
candidates are also seeing that. And this
is overall a $9 million increase from Bernie's
Q3 fundraising last year.
A P Buddha judge also raising more money in
the fourth quarter, um, almost $25 million
ahead of his 19 million from the previous
quarter. That's a ton of money for a guy who's
only polling whatever he's pulling right now.
8% is it? Uh, now we haven't yet heard from
Joe Biden. We haven't heard from Warren about
Q4 numbers pretty late in December. Elizabeth
Warren said that she had raised 17 million
at that point. That is way lower than Bernie.
It's way lower than Warren's fundraising in
previous quarters. And her polling seems to
be tracking her fundraising at least as of
the last three months. Biden, we just don't
know about yet. Uh, the Joe, the, uh, Andrew
Yang crowd is pretty pleased from what I can
see. Andrew Yang raised $4 million, uh, supposedly
in the last week alone of December, which
seems incredible and maybe I'm misunderstanding
those numbers, but in any case, uh, Andrew
Yang for a guy who's not polling very well,
pretty solid, a fundraising hall.
So what does this tell us and what does this
not tell us? Number one, this tells us that
there is a large movement of people behind
Bernie Sanders. Absolutely no question about
that. This tells us, like I said earlier about
the viability of Bernie's candidacy, what
the fundraising numbers don't tell us include
will Bernie be the nominee? Uh, what the numbers
don't tell us are, uh, also about corporate
and super PAC money. Remember that other candidates,
particularly Biden, have a lot of establishment
corporate money behind them. Bernie does not.
And that matters. That could make a difference.
I hope it doesn't, but the reality is it very
well. May, this also doesn't tell us anything
about who would do better against Donald Trump.
Now I know that there will be people who are
enraged at me having the audacity to say this,
to know who would do best against Donald Trump.
I don't look at just total fundraising. Bear
in mind, Trump raised more money than Bernie
in Q four and we'll talk about that tomorrow.
But fundraising is a fickle thing. And today
on January 2nd, merely looking at the Q4 fundraising
for Democrats, it doesn't tell us who would
do best against Trump. That's a much more
complicated question. I would look at a hypothetical
national polling, hypothetical key swing state
polling, and that will tell us quite a bit
more, uh, than what we would learn from just
looking at fundraising numbers. Last thought.
There is no doubt that for Bernie Sanders
supporters, the last two weeks have been very
good. Bernie's polling continues to hold steady
while Elizabeth Warren's has continued to
collapse. We are seeing a decreased corporate
media blackout of Bernie Sanders. Huge fundraising
numbers. Um, this is, uh, uh, Bernie Sanders
has to strike now. I just wish I knew what
striking meant at this point in time, because
it's unclear what he can actually do to keep
gaining support. I would probably start focusing
on Iowa and New Hampshire, which will be a
starting to vote in the next month and six
weeks. Uh, very important to remember Donald
Trump's still significantly outraised Bernie
in the fourth quarter of [inaudible]
2019 we will talk about that tomorrow. Let
me know what you believe Bernie Sanders could
do to make headway against Joe Biden